hello and welcome to the agenda we're
here in brussels but let's take a look
at what's happening next week in
strasbourg
could we see an end to pesky roaming
charges well that could be all on the
way under the new telecoms package meps
are aiming to make services across the
eu interoperable and competitive better
and faster internet along with greater
respect to personal data and privacy are
also on the cards the draft report faces
a vote at the industry committee meeting
on monday for the full plenary vote
expected in april
whether it's life insurance car
insurance travel or even phone insurance
having it can save your bacon but do you
really understand what's actually being
sold to you first steps towards better
consumer protection will be voted on by
me peace in strasbourg changes to how
companies sell insurances and improving
the rights of policyholders could be on
the way along with the end of package
insurance find out more on wednesday
price hikes bad service we've all been
there an overhaul has been long overdue
over to the fourth railway package but a
lobby by big railway companies to
wrestle control from independent railway
managers could derail progress under
plans companies across member states
will be able to compete for contracts
great for competition but even if
monopolies are broken up can it really
make trains more efficient mep's vote on
draft package of reforms on wednesday
and finally aiming to put the spotlight
firmly on them are 24 museums across
brussels who are joining forces for one
night only
and it all starts here at the
parliamentarian with dance and classical
music but if that isn't your cup of tea
you can always have a smooch around the
exhibitions and don't forget that one
ticket gets you entry to all 24 museums
at a loose end on saturday night
definitely give this a try